الصدام النووي بات اقرب الى التحقق اكثر
من اي وقت مضى منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
عنصر جديد يندر دخوله الى ساحه المعركه
بتغير جذري في مسار الصراع الامر الذي قد
يهدد العالم اجمع بحرب نوويه شامله انها
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
في العشرين من شهر مارس عام 2023 وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه تعلن ارسال قذائف
لدبابات الى اوكرانيا تحتوي على عنصر
اليورانيوم المنظم هذه هي المره الاولى
التي يتم فيها الحديث علنا عن استخدام
عنصر نووي في الحرب ورغم ان الرعب النووي
يطفو على سطح الاحداث منذ اندلاع الحرب
الا ان هذا التطور يمثل المحطه الاكثر
قربا لخطر الصراع النووي
اليورانيوم المنظم او المستنفذ هو ما
يتبقى بعد تخصيب اليورانيوم الطبيعي سواء
لصنع الاسلحه او لوقود المفاعلات ويتسم
بانه مشع بدرجه معتدله في شكله الصلب لكنه
ماده ثقيله جدا واكثر كثافه بمره وسبعه
اعشار المره من الرصاص ويتم استخدامه
لتقويه القذاء في حتى تتمكن من اختراق
الدروع والصلب وهو سام ومشع وان كان بدرجه
اقل نسبيا من درجه اشعاع اليورانيوم
المخصب
الخطر من كل ذلك يتمثل بالرد الروسي
المحتمل على ارض المعركه الرد الدبلوماسي
جاء غاضبا ومهددا الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اتهم الغرب بنشر اسلحه تحمل مكونا
نوويا محذرا من ان بلاده لن تقف مكتوفه
الايدي اما وزير دفاعه فقال ان القرار
البريطاني قلص الخطوات التي تسبق الحرب
النوويه بين روسيا والغرب
على الجانب الاخر قللت بريطانيا من شان
الامر مؤكده ان اليورانيوم المستنفذ لا
علاقه له بالاسلحه النوويه
وان موسكو تعلم ذلك لكنها تحاول تضخيم
الامر
اليورونيوم المستفد مكون عادي ولا علاقه
له بالاسلحه النوويه الجيش البريطاني
يستخدم هذا العنصر في قضائفه الخارقه
للدروع منذ عقود
السؤال هنا القذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
نوويه فعلا كما تقول روسيا ام انها قذائف
تقليديه شانها شان القذاء في الاخرى كما
تدعي بريطانيا الحقيقه انه لا توجد اجابه
حاسمه من وجهه نظر القانون الدولي او
اتفاقيات جنيف تلك القذائف استخدمت للمره
الاولى من قبل حلف النيتو في حرب البلقان
كما استخدمتها الولايات المتحده في العراق
فيما اظهرت تقارير عده ان لها اضرارا صحيه
خطيره للغايه اغلبها بسبب الاشعاعات
اليورانيوم المستنفاذ يمكن ان يسبب تهيج
الجلد والفشل الكلوي اضافه الى زياده
مخاطر الاصابه بالسرطان السميه الكيميائيه
لليوراني والمستنفذ اكثر اهميه من الاثار
المحتمله لنشاطه الاشعاعي
اليورانيوم المنظم سيصب الزيت على نار
الحرب المحتدمه ويسد افق اي تسويه قريبه
للصراع روسيا لوحت مرارا بترسانته النوويه
لكن تصعيد هذه المره جاء من الجانب الغربي
فكيف سيكون الرد الروسي وهل سيقترب العالم
خطوه جديده نحو حرب نوويه شامله